[Musique]
quelque chose de complètement différent
qu'on va faire ensemble un petit voyage
c'est pas la carte de la france que je
vais vous montrer mais vouloir
abandonner la carte du monde
on m'a dit de commencer par une blague
comme un conseil générique parce que ça
permet de détendre un peu de me détendre
et puis dépendre le truc j'ai trouvé un
aphorisme qui est le suivant et vous
allez le finir avec moi des chercheurs
qui cherchent on en trouve des
chercheurs qui trouvent on en cherche
alors ça peut être amusant vous faites
ça agace beaucoup le chercheur que je
suis ça agace sans doute les chercheurs
qui sont dans la salle et en même temps
ça nous interpelle et je pense que ce ce
genre de blagues de comptoir du café du
commerce doit être pris plus au sérieux
qu'on ne le fait il s'inscrit aussi dans
un contexte depuis une vingtaine
d'années où on est loin d âge d'or de la
relation sciences société où la science
était sensé pour venir à pourvoir à tous
les besoins de la société qu'ils soient
imaginaires ou réels et où pendant les
trente glorieuses après la deuxième
guerre mondiale pendant la révolution
verte dans les années 70-80 la science
la technologie ont pu résoudre tout un
tas de problèmes de l'humanité que je
vais sur lesquels je vais revenir parce
que malheureusement ces fléaux pour
certains sont toujours bien présents la
recherche traverse aussi une forme de
crise dans sa relation dans son alliance
avec les sociétés parce que depuis une
vingtaine d'années internet est bel et
bien là et malheureusement à côté de
tous ces bien faire que nul ne peut
contester
il charrie avec lui tout un tas de
complot de fake news de désinformation
et aujourd'hui avec le revers d'un tweet
le plus farfelu et le plus malveillants
des soi-disant influenceurs peut mettre
à mal des années de recherche des années
de recherche des résultats avérés
sérieusement établi et parce que
quelqu'un quelque part sur le web peut
dire des choses complètement absurde il
suffit que des gens assez naïf ou non
qui n'ont pas le l'esprit critique pour
regarder de quoi il retourne vont
adhérer assez assez assez approche soit
ces affirmations et mettra mal donc
ainsi la recherche
tout cela est difficile évidemment les
rapports que produisent la science que
produit les scientifiques sur les
changements globaux le changement
climatique les altérations de la
biodiversité des écosystèmes
ces rapports sont tous très attendue
toujours mais surtout par les médias
finalement et par certains citoyens
certains politiques mais on doit aussi
faire le constat que les politiques ne
les utilise pas peut-être comme il le
devrait
pour passer à l'action alors face à tout
cela qu'est ce qu'on peut faire
il me semble que il faut ces touches ou
chercheur à la science de prendre les
devants et d'essayer de rénover de
revigorer si on peut prendre un terme un
peu désuet cette alliance sciences
société pour redonner confiance aux
citoyens dans ces dispositifs de
recherche et notamment la recherche
publique et d'abord pour démonter un
petit peu cet aphorisme trouvé ça veut
rien dire trouver un chercheur y trouve
rien du tout un chercheur il produit des
choses il produit continuellement des
choses et c'est intéressant péter de
reposer ce panorama des choses qui sont
produites par les chercheurs
d'abord la recherche j'aurais peut-être
dû passer la première diapos excusez-moi
la recherche des produits et
connaissances c'est une de ses fonctions
premières
elle produit des inventions des
solutions techniques en combinant ses
connaissances en les organisant et en
produisant des des produits les
inventions des solutions technologiques
souvent dont 100 par l'industrie puis le
commerce et cf la présentation
précédente
au bout du bout le consommateur la
science et le produit aussi des
ressources des analyses des expertises
qui sont censés alimenter le décideur
public la sphère politique pour mieux
documenter les décisions les arbitrages
qui sont à prendre pour faire avancer
les sociétés vers le progrès et puis
enfin une quatrième forme de production
qui est méconnu et c'est celle qui est
le plus difficile à évaluer c'est sur
laquelle je vais insister aujourd'hui
c'est la production de changement oui la
recherche a une ambition transformatrice
c'était une de ces fonctions premières
il faut toujours s'en rappeler et
peut-être qu'on a perdu ce filet c'est
peut-être ça qui nous manque aujourd'hui
et qui fait qu'il ya de la suspicion
parfois du doute de l'incertitude voire
parfois la recherche est attaquée
lorsqu'elle travaille sur le génome ou
lorsque des crises sanitaires
interviennent par exemple et il faut
restaurer cette confiance est donc
restaurer la confiance ça veut dire être
transparents se mettre en visibilité
affirmer nos intentions les expliciter
et dire pourquoi nous travaillons et ça
peut faire ça que je veux aller
par rapport à cela et par rapport à
cette idée de revisiter cette relation
entre science et société
il nous faut nous donner une boussole
alors les nations unies je prends
l'entité de gouvernance mondiale la plus
reconnue et celle qui est sans doute la
plus légitime
les nations unies se sont doté
d'objectifs de développement durable au
nombre de 17
ils sont ce qu'ils sont je vais pas
faire maintenant l'exégèse de leurs
limites des critiques ont été émises
les gens ont le mérite d'exister et de
montrer à l'humanité et dans
l'environnement dans laquelle vit cette
humanité quels sont les grands enjeux de
développement du monde et les problèmes
de développement durable depuis les
problèmes de réduction de la pauvreté
d'augmentation la sécurité alimentaire
des populations de niveau d'éducation
qui doit s'élever des dimensions plus
économique et financière avec des
revenus des emplois qui va être qu'ils
doivent être générée notamment dans les
pays en développement
et puis évidemment les questions
environnementales qui se pose
aujourd'hui hanoi le la société pour
laquelle je travaille la compagnie je
vais donc la cité
cette fois-ci résolument qui s'appelle
le cirad le centre de coopération
internationale en recherche agronomique
pour le développement avec ses
partenaires comme l'inra par exemple
l'institut national de recherche
agronomique a décidé de prendre le
problème à bras le corps et de se dire
comment rendre nos travaux plus visibles
de réaffirmer notre ambition
transformatrices sur les sociétés
notamment au sud les sociétés qui ont le
plus besoin de voir des progrès réalisés
dans différentes composantes de leur
développement
nous avons réalisé des études de cas sur
trets études de cas répartis sur la
planète et vous voyez qu'il se concentre
sur les pays qui sont le plus besoin de
voir accompagner leur développement et
et voir résolue en les problèmes kaki
qu'ils affrontent en amérique latine
beaucoup en afrique
et puis en asie du sud est il ya une
grande diversité de ses études de cas
autour de la santé animale et humaine
avec par exemple l'éradication de la
mouche tsé tsé
rien que ça des problèmes de pestes
végétales autour de maladie du pardon
des mouches des fruits qui attaquent les
baies de café en amérique centrale
des problèmes de riziculture à
madagascar des problèmes de vers blancs
qui attaquent la canne à sucre à la
réunion etc
alors à partir de ces études de cas il
nous a fallu établir une méthode
et d'abord reconnaître le processus
d'innovation c'est pas quelque chose de
simple c'est pas quelque chose qui se
fait rapidement et c'est pas quelque
chose qui se fait seul un processus
d'innovation est un processus complexe
surtout quand on veut aborder le
challenge qui sont listées par les
objectifs de développement durable
on ne résout pas la pauvreté en cinq
minutes tout seul et avec peu de peu de
partenaires et en ignorant le caractère
complexe de l'innovation
ça prend du temps il ya des boucle de
feedback d'itérations des impasses on va
devoir saisir des opportunités qui se
présentent et qu'on n'avait pas anticipé
il faudra savoir les saisir
il faudra aussi accepter l'échec il
faudra prendre les leçons de ses échecs
et donc le processus de développement le
processus de d'innovation à quelque
chose de complexe le l'autre principe
que l'on doit retenir c'est que l'on a
retenu dans ses études qui nous ont
permis d'asseoir cette méthodologie de
se dire que une approche classique qui
est en cours en cours de l'évaluation de
l'impact de la recherche le
développement c'est une approche assez
quantitative basés sur des modèles des
modèles économétriques des analyses
statistiques qui consiste à essayer
d'attribuer à la recherche le mérite de
tel ou tel impact sociétal et en disant
d'avoir un euro investi dans de la
recherche sur telle ou telle chose va
produire tels effets sur leurs revenus
l'emploi la création de richesse ou la
préservation de l'environnement sur un
territoire ou dans une filière donné on
a fait le constat que cette approche est
assez erronée elle est souvent fausse
parce que les données venues des pays
dans lesquels nous travaillons justement
sont incertaines sont peu accessibles et
parfois quand elles le sont leurs
qualités et douteuse
du coup on s'est orienté vers une
approche plus qualitative et
quantitative un approche mixte qui
reconnaissait plutôt le rôle contributif
de la recherche parmi d'autres
opérateurs dans ce processus
d'innovation donc on oublie la tentative
d'attribuer la recherche seuls les
mérites et les bénéfices et de voir que
de tout un réseau d'acteurs intervient
en réseau d'innovation le deuxième
élément important de cette démarche est
d'abord de la soir au plan scientifique
et nous avons ainsi cette démarche sur
ce qu'on appelle le concept de théories
de changement qu'est ce que c'est qu'une
théorie de changement c'est une
succession d'étapes depuis des impacts
quelles ont été les étapes nécessaires
pour atteindre cet impact sociétal
encore une fois les hauts revenus à la
réduction de la pauvreté à la sécurité
alimentaire
c'est la santé du bétail etc
les protections des ressources aussi
comment pourra grâce est à cette étape
finale cet objectif final des étapes
intermédiaires ont été nécessaires
impliquant la recherche et comment ces
étapes sont liés par des éléments de
causalité quand il fallut faire pour
atteindre tel objectif
voilà en très résumé cette démarche
basée sur le concept des théories de
changement qui nous amène à relater un
chemin d'impact c'est comme ça que que
la démarche appel ce ce cheminement
c'est en fait un système d'innovation
qui se déploie devant nous avec
plusieurs opérateurs dont la recherche
plusieurs étapes des chaînes de
causalité est au bout des impacts dont
l'exemple ici en anglais malheureusement
mais décrit j'ai pris le plus simple des
traits études de cas c'est le passage de
riziculture andré gascard traditionnelle
dans les bas fonds où malheureusement
les terres sont de moins en moins
accessible pour des petits producteurs
vers un système où on produit du riz
inondées ou un système complètement
révolutionnaire pour les paysans sur
place un wiki des plus inondées donc
imaginez vous le riz en casiers inondé
c'est un peu les images traditionnelles
que l'on a à un ris comme du blé sur des
versants sec uniquement alimenté en eau
par du pluvial ça nécessite de nouvelles
variétés de aux systèmes de culture des
changements radicaux des pratiques des
producteurs et nous avons obtenu un
résultat qui aujourd'hui sont avérées
avec une extension massive de ce nouveau
système de culture sur les hauts
plateaux malgache est ce ce chemin
d'impact cette théorie de changement est
déployé ici avec vous voyez différentes
étapes depuis les ressources mobilisées
par la recherche
les produits de cette recherche les
résultats de cette recherche lorsqu'ils
sont les produits sont appropriés
passant d'opérateurs des conseillers
agricoles des coopératives le secteur
privé des agriculteurs eux mêmes en
groupement des communautés et ensuite
comment cette appropriation des
solutions développées par la recherche
génère in fine et des impacts qu'ils
soient directs de niveau 1
ce que l'on avait souvent anticipé et
puis parfois des impacts que l'on
n'attendait pas et qui arrivent soit un
peu plus à long terme ou des impacts
qu'ils sont différents de ce qu'on
attendait
les produits de telles études maintenant
que l'auteur des marchés et bien et bien
arrêté
je précise que les projets sur lesquels
nous avons travaillé c'est important
pour la suite était des projets terminés
des projets ou en cours de finalisation
dans lesquels on a été capable sur du
réel on connaissait ce que la recherche
a fait l'intervention des différents
contributeurs
et puis les impacts obtenus nous a fallu
simplement a simplement tout un exercice
mais expliciter cette chaîne de
changement qui s'est opéré
le produit final bien sûr celui qui
intéresse beaucoup les partenaires
techniques et financiers les bailleurs
de fonds les opérateurs de la sphère
politique
c'est comment finalement quantifie ses
impacts et donc on a choisi de présenter
sa sous forme de rosace ou de radars
comme celui là avec des impacts à
caractère différent autour des
ressources naturelles autour des aspects
économiques et financiers autour du
bien-être des populations
et puis des dimensions plus
institutionnelle j'ai choisi ce radar là
parce que d'abord il ya de nombreux
impacts positifs
il s'agit là de sélection participative
du sorgho au burkina faso en comparaison
et en alternative au processus habituel
qui consiste en quelques partage de
semences locales par les producteurs et
l'intervention du secteur privé qui a
pas mal perturbé le processus
cette nouvelle forme de sélection
participative et de partage organisé des
semences entre producteurs a généré de
nombreux impacts positifs dans les
différents domaines que l'on avait
identifié en consensus avec les
producteurs eux-mêmes
et puis à noter un petit impact négatif
le changement ça perturbe et on voit que
deux au plan culturel et des conditions
de vie des populations va changer de
système ça n'aura pas toujours plus mais
globalement ils ont reconnu que
l'essentiel des impacts positifs
contrebalancer largement les quelques
petits désagréments qu'ils pouvaient
concourir
c'était juste un exemple de cette de
cette approche alors notre démarche pour
des projets déjà réalisés
elle est très intéressante elle a
beaucoup attiré l'attention des
bailleurs de fonds et des et des
financeurs du développement parce
qu'elle permet de mettre en visibilité
ce que fait la recherche ses finalités
ses attentions d'appui au développement
et sa capacité transformatrice donc là
encore la recherche est capable non
seulement de produire comme je les dis
connaissance des solutions techniques
des ressources pour les décideurs mais
aussi du changement
ça c'est important et la tension était
tellement attiré qu'on sait nous même
interrogé sur le fait que avec les
bailleurs de fonds s'est interrogé sur
le fait que et si on inversait la
matrice et si on parlait du parti d'une
page blanche
le projet n'est pas réalisée il n'existe
même pas il ya même pas forcément d'idée
préconçue sur qu'est-ce qu'il va falloir
faire pour résoudre un problème on pose
d'abord le problème
donc on aperçoit matrice on regarde avec
des acteurs politiques locaux avec des
groupements d'agriculteurs des
communautés rurales dans les pays du sud
quels impacts majeurs seraient
nécessaires pour améliorer vos
conditions de vie votre bien-être la
situation votre environnement maintenant
aujourd'hui qu'est ce qu'on fait est là
ces gens-là nous disent ben oui on va il
faut faire s'il faudrait faire ça ça
s'appelle déjà le chemin d'un pack la
théorie changement avec ces gens là de
façon participative
on essaie de dérouler mais dans l'autre
sens par rapport à ce qu'on avait fait
dans la démarche initiale quel impact on
veut viser quel résultat cyr comment les
résultats de recherche obtenus pourront
se mêler aux activités des conseillers
agricoles quel niveau de formation
seront nécessaires quel montée en
capacité sera nécessaire quelles
ressources de la recherche en nécessaire
et comme cela en revente en tout le fil
du chemin atteinte que vous avez vu tout
à l'heure on peut arriver à programmer
la recherche
c'est très ambitieux c'est assez radical
comme posture souvenez vous aussi de
l'image de la tour d'ivoire dans
lesquels s'enferme parfois certains
chercheurs et il est vrai on le voit
dans ma propre organisation le cirad
les chercheurs qui songe dans la le
versant le plus fondamental de recherche
sont aussi les plus rétifs à rentrer
dans ce genre de logique mais ils
trouvent leur place et c'est donc un
changement radical qui est qui et qui
est possible on est en train de le faire
au moment où je vous parle
nos équipes travaillent maintenant à
laisser un petit peu de côté une
approche qui était dite
ex post à dire une fois les projets
terminés et à s'intéresser plus à une
approche ex ante et une page blanche des
préoccupations de développement qui ceux
qui se font jour comment nous mettons
nous en ordre de marche nous la
recherche
nos partenaires pour travailler les
leçons que l'on a appris de ses
expériences de l'expérience une fois les
projets réalisés comme des premiers
travaux que l'on fait sur les recherches
a programmé nous montre que la recherche
continuez absolument à produire des
connaissances il ya beaucoup de
changements qui nécessite de mieux
connaître les mécanismes qu'il soit de
caractère humain ou biophysique qui
génère qui gère finalement le
fonctionnement de la planète
là la recherche de aussi continuer à
produire des solutions techniques il
faut absolument continuer à alimenter
les politiques avec des ressources et
puis évidemment à produire du changement
mais cela n'est pas nécessaire pour
arriver à ce que cette chaîne soit
vertueuse et fonctionne bien il nous
faut produire deux choses qui n'étaient
pas forcément dans l'agenda initial de
la recherche il nous faut produire des
partenariats comme un levier non pas
comme une fin en soi mais comme un
levier pour vraiment que toute une
communauté dans le système d'innovation
se met en marche
sainté reconnaissent interagissent et
ensemble accompagne l'innovation jusqu à
obtenir des impacts sociétaux
la deuxième chose que l'on a constaté
c'est qu'on doit aussi produire de la
capacité de la montée en capacité des
partenaires à chaque étape de ce chemin
impact que je vous ai rapidement montré
il y a de la montée en capacité
nécessaire des chercheurs eux-mêmes qui
doivent apprendre à travailler un peu
autrement
et puis de l'ensemble des partenaires de
la chaîne alors pour conclure et pour
boucler avec ce avec quoi j'avais
commencé je dirais que des chercheurs
qui trouvent
on en trouve il faut les chercher un
petit peu et il faut surtout que ces
chercheurs accepte une posture un peu
nouvelle et dans mon organisation y
assez réticent ces difficultés a un
petit peu changé de posture a accepté
que finalement la société ben finalement
qu'au programme avec nous nos propres
travaux mais une fois qu'on a accepté ce
défi
on arrive à des résultats très
intéressants je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]